we're doing a tribute to Dolly Parton
and you did the I will always love you
yes which to me as a non-singer seems
like an incredible task because Whitney
Houston did it you got to hit these high
notes I usually would never say yes to
singing that song um but they asked me
to do a tribute to Dolly on the acms and
I was like sure I'm a huge Dolly fan so
I was like just you know let me know
what song I didn't even think it was
going to be that song like I thought I
don't know I didn't even nobody usually
sings that song because you shouldn't so
um so why shouldn't you because because
Whitney Houston did so perfectly yes she
did it perfectly and Dolly I love both
versions so like I grew up on both but
like I I think there's just certain
songs that like it's just when a moment
happens with a song like even bodyguard
that's like the biggest soundtrack in
the world like it's just when it when
it's such a moment it's the moment
becomes bigger than almost the song
right you're already defeated before you
even sing one note you know what I'm
saying like it's like you're you already
feel like oh so how do you so when
they say to you we want you to do this
do you say no at first I wanted to be a
part of it so I think that's the bigger
thing is like you can't let your ego
kind of kill the moment like you know I
got up there and I did like a version
that was yes a little Whitney Houston
and yes little dolly but also you know
tried to do a little bit of me in there
too I love this moment I've watched this
a few times oh thank you I got the
sweetest message after this performance
here you go
let's check this out
[Music]
oh I got the chills I always got the
chills from your songs even like on
American Idol all the way back then it
was always a chill factor you know that
only certain people can get that well
that's really nice that's like the best
compliment ever I but you can obviously
tell too at that at that moment I stuck
pretty close to the Whitney version so I
I think also too we're all imitators
right so you grew up listening to things
and Whitney is one of my favorite
vocalists because I'm breathing and um I
I don't know I tried my best to like
honor people but also try and find a
little bit of land but it's it's
sometimes hard because I cover a lot of
songs like sometimes people who
contacted you you were about to say I
got the nicest email after I did that I
was just kind of like oh my God I'm so
glad that's over like after it's done
and I got the nicest text from Chris
Stapleton and he was just like dude he
was like that was so incredible I'm so
glad I was here for that moment like he
was just so lovely about it and I I
think it matters even more I mean you
love to get a compliment any moment
obviously but like when it's someone
that you admire so much vocally and like
just as a musician as a writer like he's
so incredible
foreign